hey guys it is Thursday in Australia and
Wednesday for most of you watching my
name is just this is Dan and we're about
to slice in these things
if you're patiently waiting for Call of
Duty World War two to arrive you might
be happy to know that the last DLC pack
for Call of Duty infinite warfare is
about to come out as usual the next Call
of Duty DLC pack will launch first on
PlayStation and bring four new
multiplayer maps as well as a fifth and
final zombies chapter the new maps
include carnage a post-apocalyptic
racetrack along the California coast
heartland and you take on the Warhawk
map from Call of Duty ghosts altitude a
high-end sky-high shopping mall located
on the edges of the universe and demo 22
a three lane map focused on close
quarters battles for those of you who
are more interested in laying waste to
hordes of undead the file chapter the
beast from beyond will see you trapped
in a desolate military station on a
distant ice planet the beats from beyond
features new weapons and traps among
other things as well as voice work from
Seth Green and the Mindy projects Ike
Barinholtz infinite Warfare's
retribution pack releases on September
12th for 15 bucks or as part of the $50
season pass and will come to Xbox one
and PC sometime later destiny 2 is out
and aside from some short serve awaits
its what a pretty seamless launch yes
but as with any game of this magnitude
there are some issues and Bungie are
aware of them here's what we know about
Doughboy yeah yeah so far destiny has
been out for almost 24 hours in the US
which means a bunch of you are probably
already at level cap and ready to start
the endgame content if you've got your
sights set on tackling the nightfall
strike the hardest version of an
existing strike with a bunch of
modifiers you'll need to group up with
your pals before beginning currently
anyone who joins the nightfall while in
progress will not qualify for awards at
the end elsewhere if you fall off a
cliff in the Nasus there's a chance your
ghost will be placed in an area that
blocks progression of activities if you
find yourself in this situation just
head to orbit and come back and the
issues should be fixed you also may have
noticed that destiny twos clan features
aren't available in the game yet while
they're available over on bungie.net the
in-game features won't be available for
a few days after launch we're bringing
you everything destiny including guides
reviews news and all-around colder eats
so make sure you're subscribed so you
don't miss a thing a bunch of Pokemon go
events are set to launch across Europe
soon and here's the detail that
get in on that following the
less-than-stellar Pokemon go fest in
Chicago Niantic decided to postpone
their plan to European safaris an event
until September 16th the event will now
kick off in univille redonk as shopping
centers in Oberhausen Germany Paris
France and Barcelona in Spain to
participate you'll need to be over 13
with a valid ID and reserve a free
ticket to buy the shopping centers
Facebook pages don't fret if you're
unable to attend Niantic have said rare
Pokemon will be available throughout
each city during the event a selection
of the rare Pocket Monsters on offer
include kangaskhan chancy larva tah
shiny Pikachu and Magikarp as well as a
bunch of others Pokemon go players
worldwide currently have the chance to
catch pokemon gold and silver sledge
Andheri dogs anti ray ku and suicune
with each available in different regions
plays in the Americas can currently nab
the electric-type route ku ante is
available in Europe and Africa and
water-type suicune is currently in the
asia-pacific region be quick though each
legendary is only available for a
limited time and will move to a new
region soon that's everything we have
for you today enjoy the rest of your day
and make sure you subscribe to see us
tomorrow and for our top 5 news stories
are on Friday
yeah I actually stumbled on that
sentence there I covered it covered a
well I'm a professional you know where
that's supposed to be possible in it in
North Carolina dad dad dad if it is do
you have any missions sure one do one oh
that's a good one